yesterday I was at a meeting and uh I
fought it like 12 times really silently
have you ever seen somebody swear this
money part and they try to ignore that
[ __ ]
David is next thing is oh my god
did somebody break a septic tank or what
are you just haha
Oh what is going on YouTube now recently
described an ass dirty get all wants to
be hey can you help me how would I know
here's the thing you want to know a few
weeks ago with the Comic Con and a few
people came up to me to ask me for
pictures now I thought they knew what
was know I was even wearing a costume
and everybody thought and I was a Honda
without your thumb you should see how I
be a beyond the truck in a picture bro
[ __ ] I'll get a lot of you out there
don't realize what it takes for you to
get recognized for your hard work and
talent you don't want the cooking but
you don't want to know how it's made
y'all eat the food but you don't care
about your the [ __ ] that comes out the
other end that sounds disgusting
so y'all right now wouldn't be as LG up
baby let's get it let's go stop chasing
Fame so you're basically saying you want
to be famous
for the big face you'd be hydrate or
something would you need some Gatorade
you thirsty [ __ ] look if all you wanted
to do was be famous you really don't
have to do much on your you walk around
your neighborhood with your big knockout
put some liquors on that [ __ ] [ __ ]
you'll be known as famous creepy guy but
you dick looking like a tiny angry cat
issues probably times about her but
somebody help me out man I just want to
be famous stuff let me ask you something
first of all do you think I'm famous I
name is yeah [ __ ] why people don't know
who the [ __ ] I am
do you have any idea what would happened
if I walked up to a white person and
said hey you know what I am watch them
be like that but a puppy monkey the oh
yeah you're younger look if you wanted
somebody to help you be famous you came
to the wrong person
stop asking to do that [ __ ] I can't do
it I'm not famous you know what I'm no
more on that dude that looks just like
psy and make fun of that races wife
that's it That's not me I just ruin
people's lives and having to look like a
sumo wrestle [ __ ] personally if you want
to look like when you get recognized
wherever you go with no sense of privacy
you must not be that happy with yourself
listen why do you have to be constantly
reminded of your words wherever you go
you don't love yourself enough and that
is something that you obviously have to
fix on your own
look at my self-esteem my stuff is B me
straight through the roof kid let me say
something I know thank you but I'm
prettiest what every now and then I look
at myself in the mirror
smack poner and tell myself my dick is
huge if you're broken the same thing
look at yourself the mirror tell
yourself you got some nice and titty and
some smooth hair girl that a cellulite
on your legs
those are flavor craters your TV go just
like this save your food and your pee
for later
I bet I'm just you know stored up for
winter everybody wants recognition for
the things that they do in life and
that's not wrong the problem is wanting
fame without all the hard work that
comes along with it you want to be
famous have something to be famous for
I'll give two shits about being famous I
just want to do what I love and make a
career I what's wrong with just having
your personal friends and your family
love you for who you are hmm you
shouldn't need the whole world to tell
you that you're worth it you already are
my friend if anything hey I just want to
be a baller baby the first thing I'm
gonna do if I haven't become balling
it's called everybody up and told me I
was a [ __ ] not could it make it give
them a thousand dollars it's heaven go
[ __ ] themselves look I don't know if
that's a punishment because if you give
somebody thousand dollars to touch
themselves is that I do this [ __ ] for
free mmm listen do work put your heart
and soul into your crap and trust me
fame is something that will come along
with all your other successes so my
friends and tell them let's grow and you
know just god damn I thought again my
god it smells like a camel Satanism
are cold and the cards all fold and the
Saints we see your may add and we'll
look at you wrong hey [ __ ] you [ __ ] I'm
gay
[ __ ] off just playing on [ __ ] damn it